- Stop behind you and I was like, what?
- It's coconut.
- Oh my God, it smells so good.
(Eva claps)
- Oh my God, it's the coconut thing.
Okay, okay, great to see you.
Obviously you know Eva.
- Yes. Hi, nice to meet you.
- Yeah.
- Yes, hi, nice to meet you.
- Hi.
- They're tired of me.
- No- what? We're in love with her.
- Aw.
- As everyone is.
So, wait, so you guys
you play a married
couple in "Flaming hot".
We just saw that beautiful scene.
So tell us about your characters.
- Um. Okay, me first.
I play Judy Montañez, Richard's
longtime devoted partner.
She is his backbone, essentially,
you know, behind every strong person,
you gotta have a right hand-man.
And I think she knew the power
of partnership and she
really, she played that.
- Well said.
Yeah, I think that describes
your character perfectly.
What about you?
- I play Richard Montañez and he's the,
he's the legend that helped create the,
the flaming hot Cheeto.
- Best snack ever.
- The best snack ever, best one
of best selling snacks ever.
With the- with
she's always grooming me.
- I know.
(Everyone Laughs)
- She's like, lemme help you out.
- Constantly, the whole
interview she's petting
the back of my head.
- I'm just-
(Laughing)
- Jessie is fantastic in the movie.
I mean, so fan- both of these are, I can't
I was crying watching them walk out.
- I know.
Even like watching that little scene.
It's such, you do such a great job.
I was telling her, y'all chemistry
is so great in the movie.
Is it true though Annie, that you
you used to watch Jesse
when you were a kid.
- I was in love with Jesse as a child.
- [Eva] Oh!
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- That sounds weird.
- And you got to play as, no it doesn't.
That was me and Steven Tyler,
he didn't know it but we
were gonna get married.
- Obviously.
- Yeah, so that's amazing though,
and then you get to work with him
and not only work with him
but play as significant other.
That's cool.
- I, like I said, I was
amongst two legends.
Like I got, Eva obviously
have been looking up to her for forever
and just her brilliance
comedically and seeing
that she was director
and then directing this
and then Jessie, I'm, I was
in the middle of this, like,
I, all of my dreams are actualized.
Like I, to be able to be
in a story like this where
you have this man's dreams,
you become actualize
and for me to live it, I'm like
there's something happening in the cosmos
and I'm here for it.
(Laughing)
- Your eyes are like
mesmerizing by the way.
- [Eva] Yes!
- They're, they're so beautiful.
I'm like, it's hard not to stare.
So if I look weird, sorry.
So how did you start acting Jessie?
- I was second grade.
My first acting experience.
I played, I don't even know
if you know this story.
- No.
- So you know the old, like the, the
the winter coats that have
the fleece on the inside.
We turned it inside out so
that we could turn that
into a bear costume.
We put construction paper, made bear ears
and like I was the bear in
like my second grade play.
We made this paper, brown paper cave
that I would jump out and say my line.
(Imitating bear growl)
- That was your line?
- That was your line.
- That was it, that was it.
- And I nailed it.
- Yeah, nailed it, nailed it.
And I took a hiatus for like 30 years.
- And then he booked this
movie, so cool he's here.
(everyone laughs)
- You went from that to
this, that's amazing.
- So wait, so Annie
do you remember the first
role that you ever took
that made you want to kind of be an actor?
- I've never not wanted to do this, I was-
- Really?
- Oh, yeah.
- That's pretty cool to have that.
Not everybody has that,
right off the bat, you know.
- Yeah
- I'm really, I'm really
grateful and really lucky
that I get to be in the
industry that I'm in.
But yeah, I was a little kid
daydreaming about I, you know
this, and I would get
in trouble at school.
My mom would come in to class,
I think I was in first grade
and she's like, "what are
you daydreaming about?",
"one day when I'm gonna be in the movies"
And she's like, "well you You learn"
(beep)
- Learn how to read.
Oh, sorry.
- You're gonna have to know
how to read the script.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So Eva, do you remember your
first role that you ever did?
- Well, I was an extra for a long time
and I didn't, I didn't have that.
I didn't grow up wanting to be an actor.
I was like, I graduated
from college and I was like
I'm gonna be an actor.
For my mom I was like, I'm the
disappointment of my family.
They were like, oh geez, here it goes.
But no, and then when I moved to Hollywood
I was an, I was an extra for
like two years and I loved it.
I was the one who was like,
I'll do it, I'll cross.
I'll be it, I'll do it, I'll be there,
like, somebody needs to pour the coffee,
I'll pour, I'll pour the coffee.
And they're like, can
somebody get rid of this girl?
- [Kelly] Anyone else?
- Like the girl- that girl's on set again.
That was me.
- That's awesome though.
- But yeah, I, once I was
on set I was like so curious
about everything and always
about behind the camera.
No, not so much in front of,
but like, what is that guy?
What's that guy doing?
Why is he standing there?
What are doing?
They're like, there's an
extra on the set again.
- That's what I find interesting
that you are involved in both.
Cuz I'm like, even like for me
like I don't really get
into producing so much
like with vocals or
doing anything like that.
I like the one lane, like with
my, so I find it interesting
that people's brains work like that.
Like you see the full picture.
Like, I don't know that I'm that person.
So I asked Eva about
her side hustle earlier.
Did y'all ever do that as a kid?
Have any- did you mow any
lawns, do anything like that?
- When you from the hood,
you're born in the side hustle.
You know what I'm saying
- What did you do?
- This is true, this is true.
- It is true.
- Yes.
- Me, I sold candies.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. I created a whole
business proposal for my mom.
I was like, look.
I came from a single
parent household, right?
Me and mama and I was like, listen, LAUSD
they took the chocolate out,
I need you to front me $20.
I'll give you back interest, all right.
I'll pay a bill in the house every month.
And I made paper you guys.
- Oh my gosh, that's so clever.
- Cause sugar is good.
- Yeah.
- Everybody likes it.
- Supply and demand man.
- [Kelly] What was- yeah.
- Supply and demand.
- What was yours, Jesse?
- Mowing lawns too, kind of.
- Yeah, yeah.
- My parents would sell
burritos and empanadas and stuff
like that whenever my
dad would go to work or,
or to school or whatever it was.
So we, we were always hustling.
- [Eva] Yeah.
- Yeah, I feel like I had so many jobs.
Everybody's always like, sees
you in what you're doing now.
And they're like, I'm like, no, no, no.
There were many jobs before this job,
and I, I think that's
cool, I think it's cool,
actually have side hustle,
you just really have to work for it.
Cause then you appreciate it.
You appreciate where you land, so.